foreign
from your heads up display
what is left
no name no time
no entity
not a single idea about what is
the pupil is void
it has no attributes
it is the highest degree of freedom
looking has no orientation
things have no meaning
you have found Truth by being completely
lost
what remains is whatever you are without
conditioning
it is the purest rawest form of
unfiltered you
it is your duty and honor to die on this
sword
whatever you are destined to be
I am speaking to the boxless one
The Fearless One
the one who can roar for peace
then gently hold a baby
the shape-shifter
establish your Covenant with divinity by
being nothing
not a single conditioned idea this
Collective has can touch empty space
this purest truth imaginable
has the Pinnacle of unity codes
sacrifice everything into this absence
for the dark light to shine
not a single thing can be held onto
the heads up display must be empty
how can you be free if you are attached
to all these ideas and things
subtract all ideas and radically
minimize belongings
zero surface area
trust that the body vehicle will be
nourished as you stand in truth
not a single external addition
the complete end of learning
it is quite logical that through absence
potentiality is birthed
the illusion of an entity reifying
itself is the highest form of
contraction
you are only corruptable when you are
your ideas
awakeness is boxless and without
distinctions
the bodysuit is appearing in timeless
awakeness
never hold your tongue
fearlessly bring this truth into the
darkest corners of Earth
without any reified ideas
a vacuity being a monkey remains
[Music]
that's called simulation simulation
it is the complete cessation of an
entity existing in time
it is the complete freedom of unlimited
spontaneous play
zero solidity
total letting go into the mystery